a
[Música]
ah
en brasil a más de 7 millones de
empleadas domésticas y en su mayoría se
han visto afectadas por la crisis de el
coronavirus al tener empleos informales
al mismo tiempo en los últimos meses han
aumentado las denuncias por malos tratos
e incluso casos de semiesclavitud como
ha podido comprobar la secretaria de
justicia del estado de sampaolo muchos
empleadores habrían hecho presiones
sobre sus trabajadoras domésticas para
que no volviesen a sus casas durante
todo el periodo de la cuarentena de
hecho el trabajo doméstico es el tercer
sector con más casos de esclavitud
después de la industria textil y de la
construcción civil en teoría desde 2013
las empleadas domésticas tienen derecho
a un empleo formal con ocho horas de
trabajo diarios un día de descanso por
semana e incluso dinero extra para las
horas trabajadas fuera de esta jornada
pero estas condiciones rara vez se
cumplen no hay fiscalización y la
desigualdad estructural de blas de
brasil propicia la explotación
[Música]
en méxico las más de seis décadas de
lucha por los derechos de las y los
trabajadores del hogar no había rendido
frutos sino hasta el año pasado cuando
en mayo de 2019 se aprobaron reformas
legales para dotar de beneficios a más
de 2 millones de empleadas domésticas en
el país ahora por ley deben contar con
un contrato por escrito que estipula la
cantidad de horas de trabajo la
remuneración y periodicidad de los pagos
así como pago de vacaciones y días de
descanso deberán tener también acceso a
servicios de salud y seguridad social
sin embargo la crisis económica derivada
de la pandemia de kobe 19 puso en
evidencia una realidad que ya se
anticipaba la dificultad de vigilar el
cumplimiento de esta nueva ley
marcelina bautista activista y fundadora
del sindicato de trabajadores del lugar
ha denunciado que a raíz de la pandemia
los empleadores comenzaban a despedir a
sus trabajadoras domésticas sin un pago
de por medio
[Música]
de los 2.7 millones de trabajadores
extranjeros en qatar 173 mil de ellas
son mujeres empleadas en el servicio
doméstico que según un informe publicado
en octubre por la organización amnistía
internacional muchas veces están
sometidas a abusos en esta investigación
que contó con 175 mujeres asegura que la
mayoría de ellas trabajan más de 18
horas diarias por un salario que está
por debajo de lo establecido muchas de
ellas son víctimas de acosos físicos y
también sexuales y ninguna de ellas
tienen poder su pasaporte que según esta
política de visas de caza la en el cual
el empleador tiene la potestad sobre el
empleado y que se extiende en oriente
medio'
ellas no tienen ningún poder para
decidir cuándo salir del país en qatar
ha dicho que está investigando estas
denuncias como lo hizo cuando se
denunció los abusos contra otros
empleados extranjeros en el marco del
mundial de qatar del 2022
[Música]